alexa what's the date today today is
tuesday september 29th
oh so i can help you celebrate birthdays
alexa stop it
oh is that taking place today
that's taking place all the time yeah
this will be more
hopefully more educational
and hopefully hopefully family friendly
eric yo are you wearing a dark red
shirt uh it's a sweater
but yeah it's cold here it's like in the
low 60s today
i'm also wearing it oh oh we're matching
that's nice
okay we didn't plan this but uh no no uh
all right did you prepare it we should
probably tell people what we're doing
we should yeah um i i kind of gave the
rundown
but uh we should also make sure we're on
the same page
yeah don't want any misunderstandings so
it's three plus two blitz first to six
and a half six months yes wins a match
if we're tied six and a half to six and
a half we play 3-0
until there's a winner yes and
you're white every game you're going to
play e4 every game
and the first game we'll see yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah just whip out some d4 uh
yeah i don't want you to do that from my
prep first game is stafford gambit
yes and probably that will be the only
stafford gamut of the match i don't know
if either you know i might i might we'll
see how it goes no um
i yeah my goal is to play as much unique
stuff as possible hopefully
wait that's my goal too okay well there
we go it'll be more exciting that way
and
also tonight's the debate eric did you
know that yeah
people are reminding me in chat but it
seems like people
in chat are more excited for this than
anything else
taking place in the world well this is a
very very intense
uh debate in in and of itself i was
going to
say i think the only thing remaining for
me was um
what what are we what are we wagering
because i think somebody said that um
i originally said 50. i don't even know
if you're cool with that
oh that's that's fine okay because
someone was like
eric wanted to make it 69 which is a
very peculiar number i don't i don't
know why you would
that that was just random people in chat
sometimes they'll say that where they'll
they'll say that i want something but
uh i'm i i'm neutral
whatever way um i mean it's easier i
don't know how can you
gift uh an odd number of subs yeah you
can just customize a number
oh okay um i'm i'm fine either way
i feel like 50 is a more family friendly
number
i i i really don't know the difference
um but yeah 50 uh
50 is good you know that's uh that's
like
half a video for eric on youtube at this
point so it's
uh he's we'll see yeah we'll see how
much viewership this uh
this acquires on youtube i think the
last one performed well
i think so and then we'll i guess we can
reconvene afterward that would
that would make the most sense i mean if
it goes to all 12 and potentially into a
tiebreaker we'll we'll we'll see but
yeah i mean assuming we're both alive
afterwards and not uh
yeah not dying in pain then yeah i'll be
happy to
to have some post game reflection
whatever happens
see you soon eric all right good luck
oh what happened to my face
there's my face okay all right so the
games will start
i guess momentarily so levy can levy has
like
admin power okay games are starting okay
stafford time
i just want to blitz out the opening
because i feel like i'm going to be in
trouble in the middle game
and d3 expected and then maybe knight c3
maybe f3 so he's playing near ditzki's
line
bishop e2 expected
so i prepared this
i usually play h5 but i know he's not
going to fall into this like
fishing pole trap so this is a secondary
line
usually recommended by uh by the engine
objectively white spider here i've never
seen g3 before though
i guess he's just going to play this end
game so he'll be up upon all of the
bishop pair
um oh there's some comp
yeah g3 is not recommended by by
nereditsky oh wow
so he's inviting bishop f3
which maybe is kind of risky or g1
because there's 92 ideas
i always have bishop h5 let's play this
wow he castles i forgot that's legal
um i guess i'll castle queenside i'll
try and make it sharp
so i'm preventing c3 because now d3 is
attacked knight d2
i guess there's bishop e2 but probably
just bishop h5
if i've never had this line before in
stafford
i mean partly because i usually don't
play knight g4 and it looks playable
h5h4 can't complain with this
uh oh do i get my pawn cube
i could get my my indestructible pawn
cube
but i kind of want to keep the bishop
here
uh i'm conflicted
let me keep the tension let's do it
okay so i want to
i mean i have a pretty good scoring with
uh the pawn cube because i don't get it
too much
even though people people in the youtube
comments past
present and future will say pawn square
but if if it survives throughout time
then it's three dimensional
i don't know oh maybe i won't get it
that's kind of sad
i want my pawn cube he wants to
he wants to revoke me to take on e3
um this is kind of a cute move but
probably just terrible
uh what else to do and there's f6
i'm just down the pawn oh there's
actually some bishop d4 move
so i guess f6 is uh the way to go
i'm so disappointed i'm not getting my
pawn cube
after a5 i have a choice between taking
and bishop
bishop d4
time is okay i always have to consider
the idea of bishop e2
i think i'll play this i mean
i'll play this and there's a small trap
if you play c3 i take and win d3
he's not gonna fall into that
it was a close call felt like if i took
i would open
the center oh thanks for subbing dj
something something um
yeah the alert box will stay on let's
take with the
okay okay still down the pawn but
i mean i have life
i have uh so he has no files to work
with no half a win files even
i have two half open files he has two
center pawns
okay c5 is oh c5 probably loses a pawn
so the bishop let's retreat the bishop
maybe go for some pawn break
i'm also discouraging knight b3 king f3
i'll play c5 now
okay so knight b3 i take um
i probably want to do this in some kind
of
uh like f5
and knight f3 is possible well c3 is now
possible
but he does have to be careful what
pawns he pushes
because pawns can't move backwards
yeah so now i want to maybe fantasize
about c4
and b3 is a nice prophylactic move
because i can play h5
just trying trying to poke holes in this
ultra solid position
a c5 could potentially be weak
let's do this if he takes i play rook a
chair i win back the pawn
also i defend g7 i might want to play g5
because emotes
i already played f6 spam a small time
advantage
there's also f5 as an idea take and then
take try and use the pin
at the position for white is very very
solid
okay i think the rook wants to be here
now i'm threatening to take and maybe
rook h2 or
h3 but yeah he's being very safe here
i kind of just have to wait i'm thinking
about g6 f5
could be interesting maybe maneuver the
bishop to c6
just have to keep up the pace
he wants to play g for g5 i have f5
deep breath thanks for the bits
okay so keeping the files closed i keep
as much tension in the position as
possible
having g6 here been watching you for the
longest time on yt and have been
crushing my friends with
oh that's nice stafford thanks to you
glad i think that's when i see you catch
a stream
okay this is a cool line actually i'm
sacking another pawn in the end game to
play
b5 look at this move
i'm not sure if i take with a or oh he
doesn't even take it
um hmm
play rook here first i can also just
play b5 immediately
i'll play b5 immediately and take with
the a pawn
towards the center
now double up against this pawn which is
now weak
keep the time advantage here's h4
interesting idea oh he plays it first
now i can play this
okay one back the pawn let's go
[Music]
one looking to be on b6
to be aware of knight f6
i can take that if i take
what to do maybe
maybe b4 first doesn't feel right to
close down the structure but i can
always exchange
when needed this move
d3 is weak
okay now i'm winning a pawn
can win b3
it's still a tricky end game
okay so i'm stopping rook b i want to
watch the b pawn
it might just be winning
oh wow that's a good move
it's a really good move
it takes takes
okay forking the pawns i think i'm
guaranteed to win one of them
okay
wanna push with check crazy game so far
check
i have no idea what's going on it's
really complicated
wow what is this
why am i getting needed queen f3 queen
c6
bump two pawns
oh no no
i'm getting mated uh there's my queens
ah was it just forced me i didn't see
queen b8
maybe it's for i don't know wow what a
game
that was a crazy game okay
next scene starts okay let's play
i'll play cecilia
okay i i've i felt like i played well
except for the fact that i lost
but what to do
okay let's be solid
i know he plays this uh this sort of
stuff
play this move
okay just gotta stay focused
okay let's do this i think he plays 92
here
thanks for subbing coverage
okay 93 is uh a bit out of my prep
i think i'll just play d6
i was preparing d6 against 92.
so i know he likes to go for g4 if i
castle
so like g5 wow
assuming he wants to play like some f4
move
i think i'll play rook b8 and just go
for like b4 or b5 b4
so i'm gonna have a fight
i don't mind this position
there's some other line i was preparing
where i play b5 and just sack it and
then get the b
file oh he wants to mate me so tricky i
have 95.
i can also castle casting looks
interesting
kind of risky
actually 95 95 looks really solid
because then the other knight can come
here if he ever plays f4 i'll have
knight g4
and i want to go invade his uh
i mean at least invade the center square
pressure c2
the knights will come come alive
hopefully
yeah so he's trying to like coordinate
some attack but uh
at least for now i have i think i have
better piece harmony
i mean the plans are a bit more clear
for black
it's not entirely clear what's uh
white's doing here
it's playable so i guess idea if i play
knight d4 he takes takes
might as well play this first
there's some cases where white wants to
castle queensland but probably not here
so keeping the options open b5 also
prevents knight b5 in the event of
ticks etc
actually not sure what to do here
maybe some kind of b4
i could also just play knight d4 queen
b6
i think i'll do this it's nice and
positional i think i'm likely to get the
bishop hair
there's a crazy line up here i can take
a knight of three and
trade i don't know if that's good but he
doesn't go into it
whoa it's curly queen with a raid thanks
curly queen
uh if you're just joining i'm playing a
match so i'm not really focusing on chat
but um i really appreciate the raid uh
if a mod can give a shout out to curly
queen
you know a very active twitch streamer
i'm currently playing a match against
levy rosman
gotham chess we played one very
hard-fought game
this game is going better he won the
first game
first to six and a half wins the match i
like this pawn against the knight
knight's very restricted the bishop's
restricted this knight is
has the most bragging rights but isn't
so impressive
so he moves back
and queen 85 is a candidate move
i think i'll play queen a5 just to
tickle i'll see what he does
and try and make him think thanks for
subbing oh curly queen
appreciate that maybe gifted a sub or
maybe not i'm not sure
but thanks so much
okay now i have another time advantage
okay so here there's a few different
options i can take
take once should probably take on f3
first i think i want to keep queens on
the board
uh for two reasons i think my king is
safer and
he's lower on time so i want to keep
tension and i have bishop h6 ideas
i've see file ideas too like bishop b7
rook c8
some a5 b4 ideas
just have to maximize my ideas play a5
first
i might throw in bishop h6 why not
get the queen out of there if f4 i have
e5
really uh e5
i guess i need ideas to take an a5 is
weak
so i should probably play b4
play b4 fix the c2 it does give him the
c4 square
but now i have i have a very clear
threat the knight's very restricted
is he just ignoring my threat
let's do this
oh rook g5 positional per trojan sack
uh let's just take it and let's trade
bishops
okay nice position let's stay calm oh i
could get a i could get
maybe a pawn cube there's more pawn q
potential
the c file's so nice for uh for me
and the king will find safety you might
play f4 just to
create some spiciness and now the
c-pawn's pinned
he wants to maneuver the knight okay
i'll castle probably rook f4
yeah this is uh just domination that was
a nice game
happy with that game oh we can't rematch
because
i'm i'm black every game but he'll auto
start the game
okay what else did i prepare i forget
what i prepared
i'll play i'll play an alekhine
i look i looked at like one weird alakin
line that he plays
i think this and then some rook a3
random shenanigans
ah he's not going into it okay i'll play
a vienna i guess
i looked at vienna a little bit hey it's
gary gifting a sub
thanks gary
ah siri i don't know i was not talking
to you
siri quiet um
okay f5 f5 is like the i think the most
fun line for black
then there's some long variations
starting with this this this this
i think bishop e2 knight c6
bishop etc i don't know d4
i i reviewed this like right before the
match kind of
yeah knight c6 and then this this this
this
knight e2 then i take on
c3 this is all memory so far
92 i take bishop e3 and then there's
this cool knight b4 idea
knight b4 to d5
uh there was some game i think it was
who was it justin wing against carissa
yip
oh he castles okay so this is a slightly
new position
for me i'm wondering if i can still go
for the same
idea of knight b4 it's interesting
like before he doesn't have rook c1
um
i could also just play bishop
bishop c5 actually looks really natural
here bishop c5 and then just castle
i think i'd want to castle kingside
i guess he has a knight f4 uh
i should have made an effort to
understand this position more
because m4 is kind of annoying
i mean like b4 immediately things can
get really messy
i guess if he plays not a four he can't
win c3
let's just castle
so i am oh chess.com doesn't tell me in
the material
i get spoiled playing on lee chess so
i'm up a pawn right
uh i'm up a pawn but c3 is kind of weak
he can take
it but if he takes it i have uh bishop
d4
um knight f4 is like the i think in the
spirit of the line
bishop h6 wow so he's not threatening me
yet
but what to do in rook f7
bishop h5
i could play king h8 king h8 looks like
a save move
bishop c6 i have to take with pawn this
is okay
safety first still have to keep an eye
for this idea
because i'm not too concerned about b7
and c2 looks very tasty
oh i have triple pawns now
i guess i know no longer have knight
before but i have the bishop pair
threatening to take on h6
this is a cute idea
it's kind of like a puppy
it's so adorable alfine hello the bishop
and i'll try and win a2
and i'll hold on to this c3 pawn
bishop b2 oh he wants to do things on
the king side
i don't think i'm too terrified
i mean rookie one expected this could
get sharp
take on e2 he has e6 ideas
i might want to play my bishop's really
out of it but i want to play rookie 8
first
rookie a7 hangs
bishop c5 is coming too my bishop's just
completely out of it
okay let's stop bishop c5
that was a bad idea i was just terrible
that wasn't
really cute or adorable
but that's okay i'm still up upon have
the bishop pair
he's running tricky things king g8 now
now looking safe on g8
i probably just want to do this in chill
bishop e7 is my replacement for netflix
i have to do something in chill
oh he wants to attack me okay let's
start with bishop e7 he wants to rook
lift i could bishop lyft
scary the queen's a little bit
vulnerable
this bishop i mean let's try this
first i'm just curious what he's up to
and queen h3 maybe i mean there's some
g5 ideas
oh g5 is very spicy i always have to
watch out for e6
i don't think e6 is too scary though if
i play oh my time
i think i just have to do this and pray
g5 let's go i don't know if it's a bad
move or a good move it's so spicy
so g4
yeah who knows what's happening here
there's lots of resources just concerned
about my time
oh my f pawns pinned to my queen
um now let's do this
yeah there's no great fork wait what is
this
oh he also played knight g6
now well played
i guess i could play some queen move
i'm in big trouble here though i think
f5 is kind of hanging
i'm trying to calculate but it's so
messy i have five seconds left
i'm expecting queen f5 and it's gonna
just explode
probably in my face
queen f5 takes a knight takes on f4
takes on e6
everything's hanging in that line bishop
d4 is always a concern
he wants to meet me
oh good move
da
no there goes all my pieces
i still have the c pawn though and now
the a pawn
it's really bad oh there's a free thing
can i stalemate myself
ah
i just want to steal me myself
i resign ah that was unfortunate that
was a cool position
i don't know what was going on there but
he kept attacking me
ah good game well played
okay so it's two to one um
i think next game i'll play a french
i'll play like some kind of slower
i don't know what he'll play maybe he'll
play b3
i was expecting or i was preparing for
b3
after which i'll play a sicilian
oh he's playing knight c3
um let's play c5 i'll have another
sicilian
and he can't play he can't play his a3
line except i guess he could
it doesn't make as much sense in this
position though
uh maybe he'll play grand prix i kind of
tricked him into
like i don't think he usually plays this
move order
okay
actually i've i play this line for both
colors
looks like he'll play a close sicilian i
know he taught
he taught box boxes opening this is all
box box did in pog champs
with both colors
really i guess i should take a knight c6
so unexpected open sicilian
white's wasting a little bit of time but
it's playable
refrigerator thanks for subbing you da
best oh thanks
you also the best i guess knight f6 idea
knight g4 maybe
there's also ideas i mean the queen's a
bit awkward here
i think 95 should be played sooner
rather than later
like maybe even right now i don't know
uh i mean let's do it right now
freeing open ideas of rook c8 i mean
there's a lot of ways this could go
wrong for white
b3 interesting okay so i'll play rook c8
i guess this is a logical home for the
bishop because the queen's in the way
of the normal development
so i think what i want to do is play
bishop c5 and d6
and just kind of chill
oh there's some b4 idea maybe to snag
the pawn
and queen d2 probably expected
queen d2 oh queen g5 what is this
okay so first question can i play d6
sacked the pawn and try and trap
the queen there's queen h6 knight g4
queen d2
i mean knight g6 is a safe
safe move there's really not too many
options here
i think i should just play knight g6
e5 i don't think i'm too concerned about
let's play knight g6
it's a good thing my bishop's defended
hmm i'm up on time if for some reason i
thought i was down on time
okay that's good
so i could play queen v6 here
just a nice square for the queen keeps
both bishops more defended there's no
knight a4
and probably h6 some point soon
also i build a pressure against f2
the drawback of this is b4 now runs into
knight a4
so i have to be aware of that
i'm actually expecting h3 here
but h3 is not usually a move that gotham
would like to play
just knowing his style he likes to be
aggressive and confrontational
oh looking h1 okay he wants to play f4
so i think do i want to chase the queen
away
oh there's a crazy line where i play b4
allow knight a4 and take on e4
and give away my queen oh but then the
rook's attacked in the end
i think i'll start with this
i'm thinking bishop c6 here
i have knight oh i don't have knight g4
so d7
hangs so i think bishop c6
is a nice kind of prophylactic guy i
over defend the pawn so the knight has
more mobility
i want to play this h3 is now expected
now another benefit to this move is now
i can play b4 knight a4 and take and
then
ah but then i'm not attacking e4 but
maybe i have queen b7
it's a nice square for the queen
that's a nice sort of sicilian position
i mean my pieces are happy
white setup isn't uh isn't super active
also f2 is hanging f2 is hanging
so i guess he plays that to try and
defend
so i could trade
i don't really want to trade
i play bishop back
be interesting
i'm concerning b4 here
before it doesn't quite work if i take
i think i'll just move back and see what
he does try and keep the pressure
i'm not sure if i want to castle here
that's annoying because i feel like i
should punish this knight
or just his like whole setup in general
and d5 maybe d5 at the right moment i
think i will castle
like play rook d8 and d5 as long as he
can't play e5
okay now b4 is interesting before
there's still knight a4
i mean i can take
maybe knight g4 here
my g4 is kind of interesting
and it's going to be another crazy time
situation so my plans to take and
eventually play knight e3
let's go for it i don't know if it works
oh he doesn't take back interesting
so i play e5 e5 f5
um
let's try this i mean i'm allowing f5 f6
i calculated just knight g6 back
i bishop e3 intermeso
and this move will go for d5 thanks for
the bits appreciate that
eric you're the best crush this dude
even if he was my coach laughing face
laughing face
what to do here queen c5
idea queen c3 have to be very careful
though
okay let's play this let's be safe
safety first
oh
not good this night is stuck
i'm still alive
i have four ideas
okay pawn's located thankfully
what is this position
maybe trade brooks
i just can't allow any counter play
what's my plan okay rook i have a plan
to win the g5 pawn
let's go
defend first
you can win a3
i just want to keep everything defended
i have time
[Music]
let's go okay wow what a hard game that
was a crazy game
that was that was a really hard [ __ ]
i'm happy with the way i played
i'm happy that i've i found night h8
like the only square for the night
crazy crazy end game thanks uh oh i'm
singer cheering a thousand bits thanks
so much i'm singer
appreciate that
okay i'll take a small break so two to
two
so it's tied it's gonna be a a close
match
okay i think i'll repeat the alkyne
um yeah let's repeat the alkyne
i want him to play this and he could go
into a vienna again
okay so he's playing this stuff
let's go let's go let's go
wait a minute what did i prepare for
this i prefer a5 i think
i should really uh yeah i think he plays
rook a3 here
i mean he could do other things
but i did oh he does other things let's
play d6
okay so we'll have a more traditional
alekhine with
a5 and a4 included which should actually
benefit
me i think just because
uh this square is nice nice for a night
gall i'll try and pressure the pawns
really wait what free pawn
i mean some kind of gamut it looks like
let's take this
i want to go for e6
i'm okay giving back the pawn as long as
i can complete development
which i don't think should be a problem
oh thanks for subbing maggie appreciate
that ng
gmc something also sudden
now let's go for e6 this is a nice sort
of opening success
i mean time advantage material advantage
queen h5
a sneaky sneaky
um okay so i have queen of queen f6
maybe queen f6
there's knight b5 bishop d6 i
think it's okay
and then there's c5 in the end oh but i
have bishop b4 okay that should be fine
so knight b5 was kind of concerned about
this but bishop b4 and in some cases i
can even sack the pawn castle
um there's also bishop g5 here but then
queen g6
is uh i mean i just want to trade queen
simplify
and get some uh oh but he wants to trap
my queen
so probably okay there's two options
there's this move
or just h6 maybe or g6 even
g6 is kind of interesting but then 94.
i have to be very careful here yeah 94
is kind of terrifying
but 94 bishop b4
let's play g6 i'm just curious where his
queen's going
so h3 i can take and unleash the the
beast
on c8
if 94 i have bishop yeah okay so he
retreats
probably i can take in bishop b4
there should be four threats to win a
pawn
there's f4
i think it's okay it's kind of risky f4
takes takes there's some queen h4
that looks okay there might be inter
mesos even
which could simplify
okay probably time to oh wait i don't
want to allow 94
so probably take some takes
dangerous is that
i think it's a risk worth taking that's
a pawn worth taking
i'm up two pawns now along bishop a3
but then this move
it could get sharp if it gets sharp then
materials less relevant
it's more about king safety and
initiative
and time of course f4 so i have queen b6
as a resource
i think i should just castle get back
upon there's knight c3 as well
um what else bishop g4
i think i'll just castle
that's scary though
could also play e4 e4 is interesting
let's go for this these dark spurs are
going to be uncomfortable
debating queen h4 queen b6
i mean if i win enough pawns i can
afford to stack the exchange
like taking on c3 though looks really
risky
but where does a queen move
let's just do this let's be safe i'm
already up a pawn
i want to just cover the king's side as
much as possible
and watch my time
and okay maybe a bishop h6 i can
consider attacking the exchange
like bishop v6 knight c3 is kind of
interesting
okay maybe queen or queen b3
gotta move quick
ideas
oh wow that's a good move i have to move
back
i wasted time there okay queen c5 maybe
give me some ideas
decided not to redeem blindfold
oh yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't follow
through with that good choice
can take on c4
this attack looks really really
dangerous i just got a train
bishop d5 maybe
queen d4 ideas
okay i want to get counter play as
quickly as possible
i give rook to your queen d1
then rook to queen takes e4 some
tactical idea
[Music]
so i'm threatening this
okay i want to trade on milan queen h4
oh but then we trade more
okay i'm very much alive here
okay this should be good for me just
simplifying
oh my pawn
defend the bishop
pin the rook
i want to go for each four
you can win a pawn
as greedy move but why not
oh a lot of d3 she doesn't do
okay this should be winning
i'm giving him chances though
i keep the pawns on dark squares very
important so they work together with the
bishop
and walk the king up and then walk the
pawns up
you
this better be winning
i think it's winning
it's scary though still kind of sort of
to defend the pawn
there we go
how i make progress
let's go i almost flagged
on so many occasions there wow man he
put up so much resistance
i thought i was going to win easily but
no
even good positions are not easy to
convert
let's go so it's first is six and a half
wow so we're about halfway through kind
of
what to play next game
i think i'll play a pierce or a modern
just have to stay calm man and these
games so much adrenaline
thanks for the bits in gmc appreciate
that
need sku also yield eel subbing
thanks yo eel and lord francesco and
maggie i just see the event list
um i'll have the chat open uh he might
oh maybe i should have the chat open
because
it's longer break than usual um
did he message me
i'm fine taking a small break after that
game oh maybe not okay
close the chat all right let's play g6
let these bits light their way to
victory
thanks brian appreciate that
so i know he's capable of doing things
okay i'll play
i'll play this thing the the norwegian
rat e5 knight h5
carlson went through a phase of doing
this
or we can just transpose into appearance
i guess
i think he plays oh what is this i don't
know what he plays actually
oh he plays this stuff g4 i used to play
this
there's some like knight c6 e5 i think
i'll play knight c6 here i'm out of
theory
i mean i've only looked at one line that
he plays with this and this
but not h3g4
um maybe i should have played c6 i don't
know
um it's tempting to play h5 actually
or e5 e5 d5 and like d4 is kind of
interesting
the 25k bits back hey
don't have to haha i looked anyway
thanks ryan
i appreciate that okay
so the question is what to do with a
knight
uh i guess knight here and then chip
away with c6
so it's very kings indian like i'll play
c6 immediately
if average g5 i have knight h5
um these structures are sometimes
difficult to understand
taking and playing b5 it's interesting
idea
i think i'll do that try and get some
some play on the other side of the board
it's kind of risky
but it looks fun so if takes ideas very
simply rook b8
maybe even queen a5 uh or bishop a6
it's very binko like where
i just assume there's going to be some
compensation like more open lines to
work with
also b4 ideas
so inevitably i'll castle kingside i
might
delay it just to consider h5
um okay so we take so there's some takes
on e7
um let's go for this so takes takes
knight c6 i can take
i mean line can keep going i have d5 in
the end
not sure if queen a5 does much
it's a resource
okay so i think i'll win back the pawn i
i think that's it's a good trade like
we're basically trading b pawns oh the
knight's coming to c4 though
[Music]
so i actually have queen a5 and winning
d5 but i don't know if i want to do that
just because knight c4 is very strong in
the end there
[Music]
i could also i could actually take first
on d5
queen a5 went back the pawn
oh it's interesting
if i'm considering knight e takes bishop
takes queen a5
um i'm king seven
[Music]
maybe i'll do it
that's kind of risky
i mean just because the center is
opening up my king's still in the center
and
he has this encountered bishop but that
was like kind of a key center pond
and if i can survive and not get mated
and build up the center
um i'm just dreaming of a oh dear did i
blunder i have rook takes b2
i may have just blundered there takes b2
i have to try i forgot about knight c3
i know how i overlooked that move
oh that's really bad
that's really really bad
i'm gonna lose this probably like really
quickly too
ah like c4 is coming i have to play king
seven
yeah i have to play key seven because
the pawn was attacked
that was a bad bad decision i got too
excited
i mean at least i have maybe there's
some comp though bishop e6 rook c8
[Music]
try and get some accidental compensation
my time too man
so accidental gambit and you have to
treat
every blunder as a sacrifice
or a gamut the knights attacked
bishop e6 preventing this alexa quiet
so rook c8
i mean the issue he can just move his
knight oh am i losing my queen
oh no my queen
my beautiful queen okay we're treating
it as a sacrifice again
even though this is really bad you could
take with knight
now let's take the bishop
i'm missing my queen
take the rook how what's the damage
so rook for queen basically oh my pawn
any tricks
i don't see any tricks
the hope is ruxia then pray oh wait i
was expecting queen g6 oh that was such
a bad move
i'll play on because who knows miracles
sometimes happen right
the hope is this this and me oh there
goes my rook
ah man i felt sharp i just missed knight
c3
well it's tied okay it's tied level
match to move on from that game
i like the position otherwise i should
have taken on b2
i got way too fancy there
um i'm running out of lines to play i
guess i'll play a scandi
oh thank you jay the space hound
appreciate that
so john bartholomew style
when in doubt team scandy
uh so i'll admit um i i checked john's
scandi repertoire against uh levy scandi
repertoire
so this is exactly what john plays and
this is what i was expecting from levy
so c4 queen d8 uh knight c3 castling
queen b3
lavi had at least one game in this and
on chess.com
um oh yeah h3 included
yeah so queen d8 so this is exactly what
john plays
oh queen b3 immediately
i'm wondering if this is prep
because if i were castled this could
very
possibly be prep
because in the other line like knight
c6's idea
i don't think knight c6 actually works
in this position
huh
i could maybe just sack the pawn and
treat it as a gambit
it's kind of risky i can defend
what would john bartholomew do
man i don't want to take too much time
here
i should just i should probably play a
sad
a sad queen c8 yeah i was preparing
queen b3
with inclusion of knight c3 castling
after which knight c6 is uh is really
interesting
um i know john is actually working on a
new scandi chassis course
which he was talking about the other day
on stream
have to maybe invest in it if i truly
want to be
part of team skandy okay so probably
rook t8
i mean i know there's c5 as a thematic
idea
um maybe is more difficult to play now
i mean knight c6 still may be possible
hmm yeah love you just got a better
version of
what i was preparing i think i'll go for
c5
so i did as if takes i play 97
because okay my queen's tied down and d5
is possible
i mean maybe i taken just
bishop d6
and maybe a6 first i don't know
i'd be so curious like how john
bartholomew would treat this position
but i did check a few of his games just
to see where he places his pieces
so there's this move and then maybe i
can take because it takes bishop h2 if
takes takes
i would defend there's bishop c4 in the
end but then i take
but he would have to oh he doesn't take
too much time there
i mean do i do i be greedy
i'm scared of bishop g5
i wonder if i can just play a6 provoke
takes and then takes
and then try and just win d5 i think
i'll do that
a6 is useful also in preparing b5
is some day c4
and the position's a little bit shaky
also my time
time is very shaky at least i have
the development square for the night
so oh rook d1 defends the pawn but okay
b5 c4
could be nice rook d1 b5 bishop f4 c4 is
a nice intermeso
we might see a4 but then okay i take the
pawn
yeah once i play c4 there's no more
target on c5
and yeah c4 would chase away the queen
and
it's threatening basically to win the
pawn
but this rook wants to enter the game
the queen wants to find a more
happy square
i was down a minute like a minute ago
right
yeah he's been spending some time
which is nice
now it's hard to stop c4
bishop g5 it's hard to actually like
over defend the pawn
okay so he goes for bishop g5 let's
start with c4
i might just throw in like ooh that's a
tricky move
so i can't play knight d7
that's a really tricky move
and queen d7 runs into 95
and queen c7 runs into bishop f4 i i've
queen of fate
what's wrong though if i take
hey maybe i should just go for takes
and this looks really shaky let's play
this
i'm just trying to be solid
he might just take and it takes i
survive
i think
in 97
let's keep the bishop on the board and
go for h6
that's a good move
okay seven
what oh tricky tricky
that was a really good move
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i'm getting outplayed free rook oh it's
not free
nothing in life is free ah
yes he forgot my bishop
i'm still dead losing though might as
well put the bishop on c4
he wants to meet me
and go for this don't hurt me
don't hurt me
man he played that really well
ah he's hurting me ah
oh he didn't make me in one he had
maiden one there okay time to mate him
threatening maiden one let's go he saw
it
kind of
i just want him to forget about his time
or forget about my bishop and defending
from a distance
um
uh bishop g8 and so sad i have to turtle
up
i feel like such a turtle
please just flag
okay i was trying to set up like this
bishop f7 stalemate but his pawn was too
quick
okay that was a close game so i'm behind
i have to start playing better openings
yeah probably probably e5 and sicilian
will be my two main choices i have to
improve on that previous e5 game
um i'll play e5 so that previous game i
play the stafford
we'll go back to most likely vienna but
we'll see
yeah vienna time
i'm gonna repeat the same line
he's thinking he might play bishop c4
i honestly didn't really look at any of
this i'll just play my usual stuff
like knight a5 and then
basically just chill i'll get some
some quiet position uh i'll play
play d6 first very soon i'll take
i'm trying to play quickly here
[Music]
c6 is very typical the main setup is
usually bishop e6 knight d7
i might include h6 depending what he
does
probably a5
or a6 i'll play a5
oh okay
i probably have to take this i can play
queen c7
let's take it just rookie eight so i
have the bishop here
i mean white has a bit more space
i don't i don't think i mind if the
position opens up
a queen b6 is actually some annoying
idea
let's start with bishop e6 idea knight
d7 bishop f6
if queen here i play knight b6 and then
i can take with bishop
and there's knight g5 yeah
maybe he heard me knight g5 can move
so probably knight d7
oh let me take queen c4 i have d5
i think it's okay i'm attacking the
knight so basically
provoking the exchange
i just want to play this and kind of
chill
maybe use f file
and there's also the idea of playing d5
like d5 bishop c5
which is interesting which maybe
like fits my fits the bishop situation a
bit better
yeah let's do this
that wasn't the like original intention
there's some idea
you have this if f5 i have e5 d4
hmm
so i could kind of provoke or force a
bishop exchange like bishop c5
i'll play bishop c5 why not
and don't mind some end game i feel like
he's good at
attacking chess so i really don't mind
uh
getting some end game positions i have
queen b6
really trying to force the bishop chain
actually taking with knight could be
interesting
or just bad because he can pin me
say with queen
so what to do now maybe rook f7
f5 f5 rook f8
i think it's okay
and this is the only half open file so i
want to control it
eventually the knight can maybe come in
and try and get into the g3 square
this will be five ideas
hmm thanks for subbing this one queen b4
here
i like the position applying pressure if
g3 i can take on e5
rook f1 probably expected but then this
move knight b1 or 94.
hmm
let's see five i think i'll go for
knight c5
and it's a very pleasant position as
long as i
prevent light from attacking me
the queen's defended so i don't have to
worry about uh
dumb tactics
i think the plan is just uh oh
considering actually just going back
attack the pawn how does he defend queen
e2
i mean there's g5 at the right moment
let's go for the trade let's keep things
simple because time is getting low
i mean maybe rook f5 or i got five to
take e5
some different ideas here
that's a clever move
to do it's a very clever move
hmm
i'll just take taking queen c5 i'll play
quicker so i have the outside pass pawn
potential
d4 potential probably want to play c5
sooner rather than later
or b5 b5 a4
h4 prevents g5 he might try and pawn
storm f5 always may be possible
yeah the storm is beginning
okay so tickle the h-pawn oh each one's
not even attacked though
that move didn't do anything okay keeps
things kind of
solid i guess queen is tied down i want
to play a4 soon
it's interesting position like i really
want to work both sides of the board
there's h5 which is interesting too
i always play rook 8
uh let's just keep pushing
which i don't know what to do here let's
keep pushing maybe c5 eventually
hmm
i don't know what's going on now
that looks like a nice square though
am i winning i don't know
no checks
no checks things are defended
i queen e4 i should play queen e4 i was
just trying to build up time
there we go wow okay man these games
i feel like every game i win it's just
it comes down to these end games man
it's intense okay
so it's four to four wow this could come
down to the wire
okay
i think i'll play sicilian again also
alkine kind of worked out well that
previous game
okay i have to take a deep breath thank
you darth blood
and ammar something
something into rock dc or tariq dc
it's beginning it's becoming harder and
harder to say words correctly
uh yeah let's play this so repeating
sicilian
we've had a few sicilians i'll play
i'll play a6 this might transpose into
the previous line that we had
we'll see he could play nine of three i
know i know i know
uh play e6 here
i usually don't feed in keto but i mean
the setup is logical
go for the ventral d5
i mean d5 e5 and h5 stuff yeah knight h3
is a very
typical square for the knight i'm
thinking just immediately
rook b8 let's do it and then just b5 b4
and gain space on the queen side i mean
f5
am i concerned i guess i could castle
first
i mean g4 could come in g4
actually f5 is a very typical way of
trying to slow down the attack
okay typical close sicilian position
i mean oh plays e5 without
being provoked ah because he wants to
play knight e4
so maybe what to do
that's actually an interesting idea
i should probably play d5
f5 i don't know
it's also a d6 i mean he's gonna take
though and then still go for knight e4
and c5 could fall unless there's i mean
there's 94 queen d4
in c3 i think i'm losing a pawn there
i was looking at knight f5
i mean i might end up just sagging a
pawn
there's f6
that was actually an annoying move
man this critical moment
oh i have an idea knight queen c7 knight
d4 let's
yeah let's go for this so i think he's
gonna quickly take and play knight e4
and then i'll play queen c7 takes knight
d4
um i didn't really calculate beyond this
i just see i'm getting pressure against
the c file knight is
a bit loose
um and my bishop's happy actually
96 i can take it
i mean there's b4 here imagine before i
can
probably have some tactics against a
rook
i mean he might play v4 like trying to
stack the exchange
like before knight e5 can be interesting
yeah it's a tricky spot for white
because if i take
if i win c2 then d3 is weak and i would
have a really nice position
um so i mean these are basically the
candidate moves
i guess knight a6 is the most forcing
uh probably takes
yeah so he's getting the bishop hair
i have to take i guess we'll get some
end game
trade queens i mean
white's pieces aren't so impressive like
the knight is out of play
the bishop's tie down to the pawn
95 ideas
that's very logical oh but i have i have
fork potential
it's a fork knight let's go
oh okay that's a counter attack but then
knight f5
my pieces are coming to life
so rook d1 maybe
some bishop d4 tempo move
um oh i forgot about that move
but okay now i can play
h6
and go for h6 if it takes takes i don't
know what's going on
and there's takes takes never mind um
in 96 here
great entertainment from you both oh
thanks for that
maybe rook to e8 first
go after the pawn
so rook d1 then knight d6
i like the position still i mean this
was a nice find
it's a pawn defended at least
temporarily but okay it's still a target
and 91 would be a sad move and 95 this
is a very levy-like move
so if i take
takes takes takes g4 i might just want
to play h5
just prevent g4
oh f7 is hanging i why did i
not see that
oh no
that was bad that was really bad oh but
tactics me no
no tactics he's six is weak
all my time
let's go for this okay still some hope
now i got some counter play down two
pawns here and down some time
take the bishop maybe try and simplify
let's take and come back to c4
i'm just trying to hold on for a draw
bishop f6 so e4 can be weak
96 ideas
okay let's win e4 oh maybe i'm playing
for a win actually
yeah i'm playing for a win now i don't
know how that happened
knight's better than the bishop
i'll come to f5 no draw
i'll play rook a3 pin the bishop
oh good move
um tricky
he's asking to get mated or skewered
what's my plan here let's see my plan
in this move or k797 check
i play for a win still
and the g7 doesn't quite work
oh i repeated uh i mean it's probably
objectively drawn at that point allowed
the rook to
to come in good game wow what a game
at least i didn't lose i was in big
trouble i almost collapsed
almost collapsed
man yeah we both had chances in that
game
a little bit disappointed i didn't put
up a game
more create more torture for him
thanks for that let's play alakan again
he's debating what line to play i mean
we're both kind of
we don't really know so much oh he might
go for this again
oh he's going for this
i've never actually like seriously
studied this oh thanks
oh wow it's white man a white man
something something
gifting three subs appreciate that
he usually doesn't i don't think he's
ever played c5
so i checked his games against alakine
um but i don't know what to do here
i assume c6 eventually d6 i might gamble
the pawn actually
maybe this was better to attack the pawn
i don't know
hmm
i think this is okay
i mean this is a thematic approach just
try and punish white for overextending
if he takes then i'll have a choice what
to take back with
i might be left with an iqp
isolated queen's pawn or maybe not maybe
we're just simplifying
coin a4 doesn't do anything
oh it looks okay he can't take because
the bishop hangs
okay we have a position
oh he wants to kill me
um i have to defend
um oh that might pawn both pawns are
attacked
so i have queen c7
it's probably the most natural move i
mean thankfully he doesn't have rook c1
at least in the very near future
bishop d6 or bishop c5
or knight c6
knight g5 could be coming that's a scary
position actually
yeah it's hard to it's hard to make
sense of this
like c6 i think i want to play bishop c5
and just be
active knight g5 i can castle
oh i can castle there's no queen h3 okay
yeah castling is the best one of the
best ways to protect the king
and then very soon i mean knight c6 i
want to play positionally
so he's the one with iqp
he's also the one with a battery
okay let's castle
king safety first and rookie one may be
expected
i could maybe even sack the pawn there's
a line rookie one this
is this this but then i have two bishops
and what else okay so he's going for the
throat
oh he also played knight e4 i mean
everything is defended i think
but knight c6 is queen c2 so i have to
be careful
bishop f5 doesn't quite work
i might just play h6 knight e4 bishop e7
looks somewhat solid i don't think he'll
take
maybe he will
there's also bishop b6 maybe but i think
the bishop belongs on e7
especially against the knight
yeah rook defends i just want to
consolidate
complete development
get the knight to d4 someday oh he wants
to keep attacking me
um i mean king h8 f5 looks kind of
enticing
oh he wants to play d4 as well
that's a scary position like time
picking a chain of d4 i have f5
i'm scared of bishop h6 is this getting
really messy
queen g6 i have queen b6 as a defensive
resource
in one of those lines so takes takes
queen g6 i have queen b6
i think everything's defended there
meantime i want to play f4 and just cut
off the bishop
and go for f4 unleashing my own bishop
making one bishop happy one bishop sad
and i want to take problem maybe bishop
f5 with tempo
okay some momentum
i also have 16 seconds
so queen b5 probably knight c6
oh i'm losing a pawn kind of
a6 here i guess
okay g5 is crazy but maybe necessary
also maybe take let's take let's get rid
of the pawn
yeah let's move
so i'm down the pawn but okay things are
crazy
let's c8
anything can happen here knight d4 maybe
let's just apply pressure first
attack oh no my bishop no ah
that was a really bad move
ah 95 maybe
i'm allowing trades though
[Music]
i'm just down a piece i'm gonna fight
though
the time is low for both of us
i just want to use that file
almost flagged there
oh good move not looking good
ah that doesn't work
pawn storm let's go
okay i'll keep on storming why not
oh really okay at least i have some hope
here
even though i'm down four pawns
any hope i don't know if there's any
hope here
this is looking kind of dire
you can't spell dire without die
this move maybe
[Music]
let's play this go after f3
this is kind of sort of painful
as rook's coming in too
[Music]
ah
just give me a stalemate hope thing
and sometimes with two pawns it can be
tricky but with three pawns
it's hard to be tricky here
it's really hard to be tricky
oh okay now i can be tricky this king
doesn't have so much shelter
all right he's writing mate i mean the
whole
like he pushes and then there's some
stalemate trap even here
ah oh jeez oh that's meat
uh good game well played
i i'm in a must-win situation
because it's versus six and a half what
to play
can maybe repeat vienna
maybe i'll play repeat french two
i'm gonna play sicilian i feel like
that's giving me the best chances
he plays b3 okay so now this is one line
i
was sort of kind of expecting
and d4 is a little bit odd
i don't mind this though
i mean knight c6 is very natural i know
there's some idea 97 like g6
in these lines motivation [ __ ] oh
thanks i need motivation
appreciate that
i think queen c7 is natural here a6 is
very typical
i give knight c3 i play 6 to stop knight
b5
i think i'll go i'll go for 97 because
if he castles there's some attacking
potential
i'm trying to believe two
and bishop d6 may be casting queen side
even
c4 is interesting
and play a6
i'm actually not sure where my king
should go
um maybe i should just kind of play it
solid there's 95 here oh john
bartholomew
with our raid i was talking about you
earlier hashtag
teamscandy thanks for that
i'm in a serious match so i can't
can't say too many highs i want to play
95
maybe just bishop e7 solid move
and then and then knight e5 because he's
gonna try rook c1 like d5
also someone give a shout out to john
i'm sure most people know who john is
i really appreciate the rain if you're
just joining i'm playing a match i'm in
a must-win situation
because we're playing first to six and a
half and lavi has five and a half right
now
and my pawns attacked i played d6 i
guess
and d6 looks solid
yeah we have a we actually have a
hedgehog don't mess with the hedgehog
trying to figure out where my rooks want
to go shout to john
let's go eric i think speedhawks
okay
so r8d8
um b7 can be a little bit weak
but okay knight before i have b5 so
i think i'll start with rookie 8
this natural move aligning with the
queen freeing up f8
potentially for a minor piece
uh he wants to play h4
maybe rook d8 i mean just
optimizer rooks h4 maybe knight e5 and
then g4 eventually
if we trade i can take with pawn and get
the bishop to a happy place
yeah now d4 is a nice orifice in the
center
f4 then this wins a queen
double e pawns are actually kind of nice
here
okay so that i was thinking b5
probably b5 there's light c5 though
there's actually not too many options
here
i'm calculating uh knight knight d4
there's also bishop b4
i mean b5 knight c5 bishop c8 maybe
let's go for this don't want to spend
too much time
i have to use a clock as a weapon let's
take that
and knight t5 is the most combative move
it's kind of risky though because it's a
bit loose but he plays it anyway
i'm bishop a8 knight d4
oh knight d4 might actually i guess he
could take
g4 takes takes takes takes
hmm
i might just play bishop c8 here it's
kind of sad but
i want to hold on to my bishop hair the
knight is
a target ideal knight d4
b4 is always possible too my pawn gets
attacked
he wants to play b4 himself
so here
okay so i'm attacking the knight in my
square
it's not fully defended but you can't
take it right away
i don't think
what does he do b4 but then i take twice
knight d3 i win b3 oh but then e5
so maybe f6 here
always play f6
bam now b3 is attacked
it's getting complicated
hmm i don't know what's going on i'm
going to try and be safe
that was maybe a really bad move but
yolo
threatening 93 am i i am i think
kind of maybe not sure
i think i am and i have three i take and
then
win something he sees it
it should be seven
that was not a good move
i'm still alive though maybe it was
wasn't too bad
i'll just improve
now that was a good move
oh my thing's pinned oh
this king's weak work h3 ideas
this king's very weak
where's my tactic let's see my tactic
good position
it's king g8
playing safe
hung up on there i'm hanging upon again
kind of play for a draw
i just have to control a4 i think is a
key square
it's weird but
let's go with this
the queen's really out of play though
i can't afford to trade queens
oh no my queen
funny move i might still be in trouble
though
i think i'm still in trouble
you
you
let's go winning a pawn
oh my my king is outside the box that
was very tricky
oh it's threefold let's go
that's our first draw what a game that
was 99 moves
99 hold a number
oh man oh he's reading so high i guess
i've been farming him for raining points
kind of okay
so draw keeps me alive in the match now
i'm really in a must-win situation
he basically has rods and he's white
first time catching a stream i don't
know how to distract you too much so
good timing very good timing if you're
gonna cheer or sub
do it between games okay
i think i'll play a pirates i'll play
um yeah let's play pierce again
i didn't mind the position i got earlier
even though i really botched it
earlier please knight c3
okay let's go for this
oh he's playing a grand prix interesting
so c6 is like a typical way of
being solid here what does h3
and what he's doing here because he
wants to play g4
it's interesting wondering if i can play
d5 here
let's do it because h3 like even though
i lost a tempo he kind of
i mean he's not developing his pieces so
i'm trying to punish him
it might backfire i should have thought
this through more because this pawn is
going to be weak
but the idea so they used to play h5
provoke g5 and get in bishop never mind
i have knight g3 here what is this move
what is going on
knight g3 rook h2 d4
what is this i have h5 h4
actually as a resource i think i'll go
for that i mean he might take and sack
but
what is this position i don't
i think when he played bishop g2 he
didn't see knight g3
but who knows though
so i don't mind if i trade this off yeah
i probably have to now
but i want to go for h5 oh he has queen
b5 and then c6
okay so the idea is just to poke a hole
f5 could be fun
but f5 i just take it could get really
messy okay so you play the g5
so what do i want to do here
also what is this opening i play c5
i could just castle actually the king is
quite safe on the king on yeah on the
king side because it's hard for him to
actually break through
i just have to figure out my queen side
development because i want to probably
get this set up
but it's probably better to have the
pawn here i have to make some
maybe small concession
he's just going for bishop d2
i can play knight c6 maybe that's the
way to go
i'm always okay if he takes something
like b4 to d5 ideas some bishop ideas
maybe i should have included this
actually i don't know
[Music]
oh i guess that's one way he can try and
prepare f5
alexa stop it alexa quiet
f5 night before
bishop b4 is actually annoying
it takes takes well maybe it's not so
bad because i can
i can afford taking take and playing at
g6 and end
okay so he might play f5 if he doesn't
play f5 i do this and this
yeah now the goal is e6 bishop found a
home
i'm down a bit of time but i don't mind
the position
and this bishop's not doing much but
that's okay
it's a closed position kind of
if he i don't know what his king is
going to do maybe just chill maybe
go to f2 so won't be safe on the queen
side
oh he maybe wants to go for sax so let's
let's control squares
yeah not allowing f5 or takes on g6
oh oh i have oh i can't play c5
let's use b4 hmm
um i mean i guess i'll go
i could take on e4 i'll play rookie
first
i might play another five if i got a
chance but he might take first
yeah take the queen
actually wait no i should take with rook
actually i don't know let's take with
rook
i keep the queen defending the bishop
man i missed my night that night was so
good there bishop b4 was a good move
okay so he's going for the sack if i
could take
i'm taking maybe queen of fate
i have to take it's probably really
strong
so i have bishop h8 as a resource maybe
queen f8
my time i'll start with queen f8 that's
not a good move though so you can just
defend f2
i'm going to have to hunker down yeah
we'll have two coming
i'm not dead yet
europe d7 bishop h8
wow so he doesn't well i can't do i
i can't take because queen h7 or f2
so i have to play this first it's sad
but okay the rook defends
rook g7 might be the idea
down on time i have queen b4 is a threat
of counter play look at this position
though my bishop
as long as i'm not getting needed
what else to do have to throw pawns hope
for the best
that f5 is really strong
to take and pray
i'm controlling all the mating squares i
think
it's scary after rook f1 though
i'm just gonna call his bluff and pawn
storm
uh
okay i can simplify it's bad for me
though
he probably has a draw at least
i have to play for a win oh my rook ah
i have to go for dirty flag somehow
please flag my only hope
break through
ah this is actually a cool breakthrough
right
i make a pass pawn unfortunately it's
over
good game what a game that was a crazy
game to finish things off
wow good match gotham beats me again
oh so those were some really really good
games
um i think i had chances even
i mean like this position it's so hard
to play with low time
and we were both kind of at a standstill
i mean he found the idea of rook f6 and
e6
ggs oh no
oh no yeah oh no my match
yeah look at games
um what to do oh
okay i think we'll we'll join we'll join
the zoom call again
if this goes on youtube this this is
going on youtube
youtube people hope you enjoyed that
congratulations to
levy gotham chess uh streaming on twitch
oh thanks so much joking yeah thanks
everyone for
gifting and subbing and cheering
that was fun um
obviously it's competitive but uh and
the whole point is to
to have some interesting games
instructive games
um yeah i really tried to mix up the
openings
uh but towards the end i was just trying
to play
what gave me the best chances
um yeah let me let me prepare for a zoom
call but if this goes on youtube
uh links will be in the description i'll
try and chapter the videos
and youtube people if the video ends
here
stay tuned for more content and i'll see
you in the future